Egyptians weren't the only ones who
built pyramids obviously ancient people
all over the world made their own
versions of pyramids and they were
usually built to correspond with
astronomical phenomena why did all these
societies separated by oceans and
Millennia decide to build these
structures and how did they build that's
an interesting question and one that has
never been sufficiently answered Graham
Hancock's answer is that the survivors
of a lost Ice Age civilization went
around the world passing down the
knowledge of how to build these pyramids
along with teaching Agriculture and
architecture and art Etc and that's how
they figured out how to do it now why
did these survivors do this and how did
they survive the apocalypse that wiped
out their civilization and why isn't
there any actual material evidence of
this Advanced civilization that
supposedly existed 12 000 years ago
Hancock says that it was wiped out in a
cataclysm but he also says that there
were enough survivors to support this
Global campaign to civilize the entire
world which means that there were a lot
of survivors why didn't they leave
behind any direct evidence of their
existence these questions and many more
are not answered by Graham